I won't forgive our souls for selfish reasons If it
becomes inconvenient, we'll dispose of them
That's the work of work As a
hero, you can overlook it
And take the temperament of the lotus
Idling is good
[music]
Ahhhhh
thank
youahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh what
nail g said,
first of all don't let that magic pass through.
Now is the time for everyone to join forces
The crime of defying the Eternal Queen deserves death If
the cracks that are craftsmanship are Maze
Skills,
that's the end
me
[music]
Ah,
it's a pity to say it It
would be nice if God could give me the time to be quiet, but I can't continue with a wasteful fall
Well, I have no mercy for the devil I'll
test whether it's
Honmuragaki yeah yeah yeah  Oh
, if you don't ask Jeongjo, the
magic barrier is different from the impregnable devil's mansion.